this is Ellie Van Buskirk here with
wired.com and tricky spending some time
with us thank you so much no ways we're
not cute
I wanted to specifically make sure to
ask you about your video that council
estate video why one of the worst areas
of Paris like um is one of the biggest
council flats projects in Paris
and um it's where they had the riots the
first day right shooting these two guys
come out say what you doing I'm like you
know I'd like to shoot a video where
they're like this is we ate this in
Paris are very funny about people going
in and filming in the go because they
feel like you know if you're a duck
you're a director or you're a filmmaker
you're not giving anything to us and
you're filming us and it's kind of like
you know they're very very against it
my last few years a massive attack we
went with an American horror with
turntables and a microphone and it's one
of the worst experiences I had and my
manager about the amalgams like you know
what about their life the life you live
career I'm like you know I never want to
do turntables again so I won't go out
life and she said we can put a band
around and I didn't understand the life
think I'm like how can I live and make
my music when it's made on keyboards and
computers and we rehearse these guys and
they played me overcome and I was just
like wow well and I've always had a live
man ever since I'm done I can't believe
you know computer DJ Finkley the old DJ
thing I don't get anymore back in the
days I got it but DJ's now as you know
these pop star DJs I don't really
understand it you're playing other
people's music right now you're getting
50 grand to play some losses and the
rock stars I just really get that
picture you come up with like crazy
sounds over the years like I'm what a
little bit stunned like I don't know I
can't even guess how you're doing this
so you can you share a couple secrets
like the honest because I don't know
what I'm doing I'm naive when Maxine
quake first come out yeah I just thought
I did an album right and people said it
sounded different and I didn't
understand why and then I realized this
cuz I'm naive my first single was
aftermath and I just flute player who
would come into the studio to play to it
and he said you know I don't know if I
can really get down to this it's not
musically correct you've got to use
notes next to each other just basically
because I don't know what I'm doing and
I haven't learned anything
well don't start I was gonna learn
guitar about three years ago then I just
thought if I learned guitar it's gonna
make me no musical feelings mhm
wait and then I might start thinking too
much so I picked up for a week I had a
few lessons and I forbad enough on that
I don't you know almost a naive I really
don't know what I'm doing right I've got
clue I like something sometimes when I
go into an album like if I've recorded
for six months I think can I do
I don't know if I can do it you know so
goodness you know I'm like wow I don't
know if I can do this anymore hmm
what advice would you have for like you
know up-and-coming kid 18 years old just
getting started I say you can have your
influences but don't sound like anybody
you have to try and like all the bands
from the hey is in life like great bands
like The Cure right you knew the Cure
was just by hearing their voice the
specials are racking try not to get
involved in a movement whether it's rock
pop hip hop don't because you limit
yourself if you want to be a musician to
be famous just don't bother it's not
what it's like to have to be if you love
it do it if not if you for the wrong
reasons I'd say get a different job you
know thank you for having me on there
thank you for spending time with nad no
problem you come to the show later
absolutely man you wake you better you
want you on the list and everything I
hope so
you guys you want to come yes all right